now we're moving on to some breaking
news there has been movement on a
reported three-way deal between Poland
and the United States that would see
Ukraine supplied with mega 29 fighter
jets now Poland's foreign Ministry says
it is willing to put its entire fleet of
the soviet-era Jets at the disposal of
the U.S but the U.S says it wasn't
pre-consulted on the Move by Poland so
let's bring in DW correspondent Terry
Schultz to help break all of this down
for us Terry let's talk about this new
development Poland announcing its
handing over its MiG-29 fighter jets to
the United States they could now be sent
on to Ukraine how significant is this
update
well we have to see if it happens Claire
Poland has announced it's willing to
hand over its mig-29s to to the United
States uh we don't know yet whether the
United States is prepared to take them
even though we do know this has been
under discussion for days uh U.S
Secretary of State Tony blinken
confirmed that over the weekend so we
know that this has been something that
Poland and the United States have been
discussing and of course we hear from
Ukraine daily that they need more
fighter aircraft of course they'd really
like a no-fly zone but that's not not in
the works at the moment so we need to
see whether this happens as I understand
it the Polish government would then
expect the United States to take over
any of the rules that the migs are
playing at the moment because once they
leave so this is really a deal in the
works and we're seeing the negotiations
sort of play out in public so there are
a lot of of pieces still in the still in
play here and what is it about the Mig
specifically that makes them helpful for
Ukraine's purposes
these are planes that the Ukrainian
Pilots know how to fly that they would
know how to fix uh you if you if you
send them newer newer aircraft that they
haven't been trained on that of course
isn't much help and this is in fact what
the ukrainians have asked for there are
three NATO allies with these planes uh
in addition to Poland Slovakia and
Bulgaria also have them and the Polish
government in this announcement that it
was willing to hand over its Fleet also
called on other NATO allies to do the
same
now if a NATO country supplies Ukraine
with fighter jets to shoot down Russian
planes won't Russia see this as a clear
Act of War
I wouldn't doubt that that's what Russia
would call it but of course it has seen
virtually everything as a provocation
NATO simply taking in new members from
Eastern Europe is a provocation Ukraine
existing as as an independent country as
a provocation I think that the Russian
government would say anything being done
to help Ukraine fight back is a
provocation at the same time the west
and NATO have said that Ukraine deserves
the right and the equipment to defend
itself it's been heartbreaking for
everyone to watch what's happening to
Ukraine even as NATO decides not to step
in itself
our correspondent Terry Schultz thank
you so much for joining us with that
update